これじゃあ波動雪をですそれだけで皆さん
ずうダイナお知らせございます日村違う私の大学3年生ごろからの猛攻頃からの趣味で
あるリュウいようノア夢の新作遊戯王7分に私だぞ数人口の a
代役として起用はされていません
がったら重要なんでだいたい殺傷役の人がいるんですよそれを結構重要なポジションで
あの水撮影所でてくるんですけどまぁなんと後悔は区多部田町
遊戯王7つの社長役号はさ等の英雄を詰めさせていただいたりたい
えええええええ大丈夫かやっぱめっちゃ不安だったらてがもう今も強い彼らが私も水
言うと忙しくかもしれませんが津波にもうから全部が収録したいんですけどもある程度
のヴァッテドするかも終わってるんであの完璧な声の状態であの
くれず収録の様子をご覧くださいどうぞよ
大人の数ですよろしくお願います吉兼月初分
主人公約優雅役の姫6ん
写真あるんですね
お願いしますよろしくお願いしますどうぞ明日事件ということねじぇっ
大丈夫分
大丈夫です勉強の法案頑張ってますね頑張って下さいが近く際も僕の薬と一緒に漢文の
訳ですよねそうです
元部やらせていただきます山田将司です今日よろしくお願いますよろしくお願いします
南北声優ぽい事を書く12回ぐらいやったことあるんですけどそれっなかったロス
よろしくお願いますいい
ことなんか言われないじゃあみたいななぁ全然ないですねー本当に
結構影の方ね本読んでいるタイプです
揚げ物のほか岐阜スクールです員の方カーってこっちゃのようでした
どうみてもいいんですよこった高校の時表して線数青いてたんですよん
それはたぶんようにしかできないんですよいやの
センサーを得てましたその整数を使い方としては好きな子の前に投げて
アドレスをそのセンスから出して渡すって均くらいしかしてないんで久子悪い色が反抗
期じゃないのかな
動きはん
なかったっていう遅いなりはずけどまぁその中学2年セグランド key
お母さんの言うことがんいやなったことがありますなるほどね
あんまりでも反抗的にはどういったこと集合れだって周年のとき階段昇るだと合わせて
壁たパイプからねっ
そういえございます
はーい
ああああああ
tan
宜しくお願宜しくお願いします
でこの運や無地なっ
ますユーザーにより縦にインストールされたダッシュデュールについて問い合わせが
殺到しております
一体どうすれば
ん
あっはぁ
おうさつを振っ派
ウズ化成
とするを聞いた方がいいんですよねはっはっは
何でも多分
はじめしゃちょーらしさがああなるほどね
ぷっ
あっはーばーだっ派
まずはいいかな気がするよね83はいえーどう社長
キャラからなんですがはい早いですね
久留米に頂きゆっくりめはいございました韓国感動しますユーザーにより使ってキー
ストールされた
ラッシュデールについて問い合わせが殺到しております
一体どうすれば
4日
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
あう冊を蹴った
難しいなぁ短い保安官こそ難しいていけないですかいやすごい
笑いだけで表現するんだそうですよねやっぱ
皆さん一人一人になります
はいよろしくお願いします
はいお願いしまーす
プップップ
うんうん
あっはっは
ありますじゃあはいおったよ終わりですはい
セッターではいぜひ一つ目は
やつで最後あの強いのがまあ一番背が元デプレッションをつけたかな
一番最後の夫婦だけですうん
うあっはようございます
あっはぁっ papas パパさあ
あっはぁもういいです
アーネございますよあった私ははーはっはっは
あるいははいというわけで遊戯王7th 始まるんですけれども主演の入学を務めるに
あたってきぼぎなどはありますか
本当声優としてやっぱりまだまだ経験も浅いねー
毎日の収録緊張しっぱなし誘うけれど大変だねその
なる作品だと思ってますので精一杯いうかとしてこれから頑張っていきたいなと思った
と思います
羽生楽しみにしておりますはい頑張ってくださいありがとうございますサイトみて
いかがだったでしょ
あの気付いだと思うんですけども今門のところしゃべった言葉がふふーしかないんです
よあれ
まじか焼きの逆にのすっていう短い言葉だけで肝臓っていうのが難しい
と思うんですよね
これ大丈夫かハリアー軍団は関係ありません私肇社長は江派冊を焼くとして看板せて
頂きますので有用成分で2020年の4月からテレビ塔情景にた放送決定でございます
て皆さんごらんくださいませ
でっさらにねアニメとかで行くサイボウズにおまけっぽいなるじゃないですかあんな
感じで私はずです流量選別の最後に毎回
が手で
して強い館の紹介をさせていただくことになりましたよろしくお願いしますなんか悠遊
カードで結構難しいイメージあると思うんですけどもう本題から始まるラッシュでって
やつがすごい簡単ですよ真ん中悠様のずらしくでちょっとなーみたいな人も今回の
ラッシュでるかなとズって始めると思うほど簡単なのでぜひちょっとでも興味は行って
語っを見てみてくださいすげー
約任されと気がするんですけどまあまあさんこんな形でアニメに出れるようになるとは
思ってなかったですねまさかの社長役って言うか損壊も号はさ長も頑張ってで合わせて
いただきたいと思っておりますとだけで遊漁船ですお楽しみに
不不不不不不不不不不不不會言ってないけどなぁ
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
あっはぁ